I think the MIT Museum is a unique place, at least
in my experience. MIT itself of course is a very
special research institute not like a lot of other
universities, and the museum is the only real
institution that MIT has to represent the whole of
what it does to the rest of the world. All museums
are cultural centers, we have the culture of MIT.
What makes it special, what makes it interesting.
There are no written records for most of the
things that we have, just the thing itself.
So we're part archeologist, part anthropologist,
part historian, and we hope to imbue those same
qualities in our visitors. Every museum of
science and technology in some sense should
be a museum of ideas. Perhaps what makes this
one special is that many of the ideas we deal
with are ideas in the making, ideas that we're
not sure about, and some of the uncertainties,
some of the challenges of the research process
are also present here, and so they should be.
The MIT Museum is home to an extraordinary
set of objects that define the 19th, 20th,
and 21st century. Doc Edgerton's negatives
and artifacts are among the most precious
collections. They document a technology,
high-speed stroboscopic photography,
but they also document the desire
to stop time, to see what is unseen.
The MIT Museum also has the world's finest
collection of holograms, many of them are
on display here in the museum but much of the
collection is also accessible on our website.
Another collection that we have is probably
the world's best collection of robotics that
were created by university-based research. Robots
like Cogg or Kismet the humanoid social robots.
Very good Kismet!
There is no other place where
you can see two, three dozen
objects that tell the history of artificial
intelligence as well as our collection does.
The Hart Nautical collection is a unique
archive of 350,000 items. The interesting
thing that is perhaps unique in all nautical
technology collections is that we have this
amazing amount of historic data that goes back
to the mid 19th century, and our collections
continue right up to the present. We are actively
collecting technology being developed today,
for example the side scan sonar systems that we
have behind me. This is a type of technology that
is equivalent to the development of the x-ray in
medical imaging. This allows us to see details
on the ocean floor that were never before
capable. One of the things that's most vital
about engaging people with interest in ocean
science is the giant frontier that it represents.
I mean, we know more about the dark side
of the moon than we know about the ocean.
The MIT Museum is also home to one of the most
important architectural study collections in the
country.This documents the first hundred years
of architectural instruction at MIT which was
the first academic program in architecture in
the country. The recent exhibition Front + Back
in our Compton Gallery featured our earliest
architectural drawing, attributed to a renaissance
architect named Baldassare Peruzzi, dating from
the 16th century. We pulled it apart, looked at
all the layers of the drawing, subjected it to
scientific analysis, we also took the drawing to
the design labs to 3D model the drawing
to look at contemporary approaches to
a renaissance drawing. In other words, we
had really basically no assumptions when we
went into the project and we came out with
a lot more questions than we started with,
but for us that was the
process that was interesting.
Soapbox is a new program for adults in the MIT
Museum. The aim is to engage the wider community
a little more closely in the debate that needs to
go on in the 21st century about how we're going to
live and live better with the fruits of science
and technology. The issue of global warming has
risen to the top of the public's agenda of
environmental concerns. We've done everything
from biomedical issues to ways in which new
nanotechnologies, new materials, will be changing
everyday life. After the speakers have presented
the issues for the evening, the audience breaks
up into small discussion groups and brainstorms
what they've heard and it's on the basis of what
the discussion groups come back with that
we organize the rest of the conversation.
So what we're trying to say is, here's a place
where you can take part in the conversations
that in the end will help shape the way
we and our children live in the future.
We'd like people to come to think of the MIT
Museum as an innovative place itself, one of
the innovations that we are leading at the moment
is to create a new Cambridge Science Festival.
The idea is to have nine or ten
days each year in the spring
when we open up the entire world of
science and technology in this city.
What we're planning is a whole series of events
scattered across the community. We're talking
about plays, science writing, events, exhibits,
a careers day for young people, and the hope is
that anybody who's awake in Cambridge for that 10
days will realize that the science festival is on.
The question is not so much when will
we build a robot that is a human being…
We have this extraordinary situation where we
can work with colleagues, with grad students,
and others to try to open up what they're doing
for the wider community, and it's that notion
that really is at the heart of what we're trying
to do with the MIT Museum as we look forward. That
means that we need a lot more space, and it means
we also want to expand the range of what we offer
into subject areas where the museum
historically hasn't done very much.
We are in the middle of an exciting renovation
of a ground floor gallery space that will open up
our collections and our programs and our
exhibitions quite literally to an outside audience
on Mass Ave. For the first time, we now have
ground level visibility for the museum. It's an
important step for us and that space will allow
us to have new exhibitions and new dedicated
public program spaces which will mean that we
can do things like Soapbox much more easily.
When uncoiled, the DNA in one cell
of your body is six feet long…
Science is something for everyone. Technology and
science matter. That's the most important message
that I hope people leave this museum with.
We do see ourselves as having that kind of
inclusivity, and that accessibility agenda.
An agenda to try to draw people in to
benefit from, to enjoy, and if they want to
challenge what goes on in a place like MIT.